i couldn't be more excited to help kick
beauty week off with this
extraordinary young woman i actually
found an article about her many months
ago and i
said to the team like could we have her
on the show and
she's here so it's happening and 16
years old
she's the youngest black beauty store
owner in the country please take a look
hi i'm paris mckenzie i'm 16 years old
and i'm the proud owner of paris beauty
supplies in brooklyn new york
both of my parents immigrated from
spanish town jamaica and i'm one of our
first generation children in this
country to be a citizen
without their hard work and without
their determination
we wouldn't be as successful as we are
now we came from
not sleeping on any furniture to owning
our own home
all my life i've been working in stores
owned by my mother about
one to two years ago i started working
more independently in the salon so i
started taking
clients and i did hair and i did nails
and on a school day i'll go to high
school i go to college and then i'll
come straight to work after
one day the previous owners of the
beauty supply store came to my mom
and told her that they were selling so
she came to me and asked me if i wanted
to invest and i said yes of course
to be able to do this and take a huge
step
in my life goal was something i couldn't
pass up
i had to mature very quickly i had to
learn how to
handle money how to handle business at a
very very young age
there are so many people that are in
young people's ears like
you can't do it yet so seeing my story
should help them erase
all of those negative thoughts so they
can go and try to achieve whatever they
want to in life
i just want to be able to give them the
opportunity
to build up that courage and give them
that motivation
okay i was redoing my homework on you
last night and i was reading this l
article that you did first of all like
bella hadid
and janet jackson was tweeting
and instagramming about your story
and one of the things i loved in the
article was that you said you know
you have like a very amazing prowess for
salesmanship
and identifying what a customer when
they come and you say i clock their
style
kind of who they are and i think
intuitively i know maybe
what they need and that you yourself
when you would walk through stores did
not only not get assistance
but not really any help at all in fact a
bit of the opposite
so what about your experience made you
be so proactive well
um when i was in beauty supply stores
and when i would walk in
i wouldn't get the experience i felt
like i needed
being black and having natural hair and
being young as well not really knowing
your identity you kind of want someone
to help you
be guided on your path yeah and i never
got that experience so
being the person that i am i wouldn't
want other people to feel the same way
i did so i thought let me use this store
as a way to empower other women or
any gender and empower people who don't
get that experience so they can
love themselves and make themselves more
beautiful
you're 16 yes paris what is going on
you act and look so mature
you're balancing homework and college
and running a business how do you think
that you became i started young too and
i don't even have anything to pull from
i'm just staring at you in awe how do
you do what you do
well i have a schedule set now and i go
to high school in the mornings
and i go to college in the afternoons
but it's only two days a week
and then i'm in the store the whole day
until after eight o'clock
and then at night i go back to high
school work
and that's a schedule i have but really
the work ethic i got was from
watching my mother she's an entrepreneur
herself
and she owns two businesses as well and
just watching her
and growing up around her is what really
what taught me
to be what i am now and how to have that
worth like
ethic and that determination well as a
mother of two daughters
i can only marvel at your
and your mother's grace it's just so
inspiring
and it's so just dope and awesome and
cool and inspiring as well as really
elegantly pointed in business
organization
prioritizing i want to introduce you to
a trailblazer
in this beauty industry and after
working with makeup for over a decade
and feeling like there was still a void
in options for black women she took
matters into her own hand and created
this company
ama and it's uh sharon shooter who's
here
sharon hello hi hi guys from los angeles
sharon i have so much to talk to you
about today but with paris i mean when
you hear her story does it
feel reminiscent of your own is there
parallels
what are your thoughts oh my god firstly
i'm blown away
paris you are amazing i am a super fan i
love what you're doing
and yes there is so much parallels
because uh people a lot of people don't
know this about my story but i actually
brought revlon into nigeria when i was a
teenager
so my story is very similar to yours
really starting that entrepreneurial
path
while i was really young i mean i wasn't
as young as you i was only a couple of
years older than you were
at the time that i did that so i'm
amazed i'm in ore and i
could not be proud of what you do right
now all time and
your store paris is so extraordinary
i've looked at the shelves and the
stocking
and your curation and your knowledge of
the products and sharon
we're going to talk in the next segment
about all the pioneering
you've done and i believe you have
something for paris yes i
do paris so i am such a fan of what
you're doing
and i would love to support you in any
way i can and there's two ways today i
would love to support you
first part is your education because
it's so important very similar to you
i did start an entrepreneurial path but
i did go back and continue working and
continue studying so
i would love to contribute five thousand
dollars towards your education
to make sure that it continues because
it's super important
and the second thing i would love to do
is
also give you five thousand dollars
worth of products as well
from i'm a beauty so that you can
display them proudly
and i hope in doing that you get even
more beauty brands support
you and come on board on your shelves
but i am beyond proud
well done thank you thank you so much
thank you so much you really are the
shining example
i mean you just have blown me away since
i found out about your story several
months ago i am so honored to
be on a show with you work with sharon
shine a light i'm just i'm really
impressed with you
and i think you have so many things in
your brightest of future
and so many people to carry and lift up
with you
because you've clearly figured out a way
to pull this all off so
thank you paris sharon we'll be back in
a minute to talk more with you right
after the break
thank you paris